le département de La Réunion au côté des
réunionnés l'assistant maternel est la
personne qui moyenne en rémunération
accueille habituellement et de façon non
permanente des mineurs à son domicile ou
dans une maison d'assistant maternelle
ces enfants sont confiés par leur
parents pour exercer ce métier il faut
obtenir un agrément délivré par le
président du conseil départemental de
son lieu de résidence les assistants
maternels peuvent travailler de façon
individuelle à leur domicile ou en se
regroupant au sein d'une maison
d'assistant
maternelle qui peut devenir as SMAT pour
obtenir l'agrément le candidat doit
présenter des capacités et qualités
personnelles pour accueillir de jeunes
enfants dans des conditions propres à
assurer leur développement physique
intellectuel et aptitude éducative
satisfaire un examen médical afin de
vérifier que son état de santé est
compatible avec l'accueil disposer d'un
logement dont l'état les dimensions
l'aménagement et l'organisation de
l'espace permett d'assurer bien-être et
sécurité des
enfants qui contacter il faut contacter
le service de la Protection Maternelle
et Infantile pour avoir plus
d'informations au 0262 90 39
33 rendez-vous sur le site du
département www
cg974.fr rubrique enfance devenir à
[Musique]
SMAT